[Music]
are you ready to join vapenation
vapenation and we mean really join it
because you'll be vaping for 24 hours
straight no breaks okay maybe we'll let
you go to the bathroom let's find out is
vaping really dangerous
what would vaping for 24 hours do to
your lungs and is it possible to
overdose from vaping this is what if and
here's what would happen if you vaped
for 24 hours straight how dangerous is
vaping exactly well we're not entirely
sure yet according to the Centers for
Disease Control there have been about
2,300 vaping related medical incidents
in the United States many of these
patients were suffering from chest pains
and nausea but nearly 50 people have
died from vaping now keep in mind that
there have only been a couple of
thousand issues among 35 million vapors
worldwide so sure it's probably far from
being a health food and vaping should
probably be done in moderation but let's
throw all that out the window and vape
for 24 hours straight just because we
can first we need to figure out what
kind of vapor using let's go with the
variety that contains nicotine as it's
the most common kind of e-cigarette how
many puffs would you even be able to
take in a single day well let's say
you're really into vaping so you want to
take a puff roughly every single minute
in between bites of food
you're going to the washroom and
definitely when you're sitting on the
couch if you were to do this you could
take 1440 puffs of your vape in 24 hours
fat clouds bro if that doesn't sound
like a lot to you let's put these
numbers in perspective a 2015 study
found that on average a vapors daily
puffs intake is about 132 so multiplying
this by more than 10 would be quite a
lot of vapor man and yes we do mean
vapor since e cigarettes don't actually
produce any sort of smoke even though it
can get smelly and appears like smoke
from a cigarette it's just water vapor
and either propylene glycol or vegetable
glycerin but your vapor filled room will
actually be the least of your worries
once you're about halfway through your
10 milliliter cartridge of galactic milk
vape juice now you're starting to feel
queasy that's because you might be
starting to get nicotine poisoning yeah
sorry about that we probably should have
warned you off the top so how did this
happen anyway well if your vape
cartridge is lightly nicotine flavored
that gives you about 12 milligrams of
nicotine per milliliter of vape juice
and once you're about 500 puffs in your
epic vape sesh
you'll be about halfway through your
courage this means you've just inhaled
60 milligrams of nicotine which is
equivalent to about 60 cigarettes
according to the CDC
this is enough to get nicotine poisoning
although some research suggests
otherwise regardless of the specific
numbers smoking this much in such a
short period of time can't be good and
will most likely result in some sort of
nicotine poisoning this doesn't mean
you're overdosing which would result in
death luckily for you
researchers think this is almost
impossible to happen that's because by
the time nicotine reaches a lethal
concentration in your body you'll end up
vomiting all over the place and it
wouldn't just be coming out of your
mouth either
it would be coming at the other although
nicotine is used to relax and keep you
at ease you'd be experiencing the
opposite with heart palpitations and
fading in and out of consciousness this
would definitely be scary and gross but
it would flush the toxins out of you so
you won't die this time and if you're a
vapor who doesn't use nicotine then
you'll still have some things to worry
about the heating element in an
e-cigarette emits tiny particles that
include metals these can be dangerous to
the lungs and get into your circulatory
system these particles have been linked
to things like high blood pressure and
heart attacks so if you were to do this
for 24 hours straight there's a good
chance you'd end up in the hospital
let's face it there probably isn't a
single thing that you should be doing
for 24 hours straight if you are going
to vape try not to do it for that long
please another thing you shouldn't be
doing for 24 hours straight is going
without sleep what would that do to you
well that's a story for another what if
you